House of dragons uh these guys know
nothing so you're useless go pee or do
something
yo these [ __ ] nerds and everything
cool cool guy conversation let's go
miles
Schultz the cool guys I enjoyed the
season I thought it was very well done
for 10 episodes I only have two Duds
excellent I'm with you on excellent yeah
and also dealing with the highest
expectation in history yes you're coming
up every episode is put up against a
Game of Thrones episode it's not put up
against a White Lotus episode I just put
up against the episode it's put up
against the whole [ __ ] series exactly
you're not even comparing the whack ones
to Seasons like seven and eight where
the show kind of fell off you're
comparing it to the best parts yeah and
I feel myself doing that and it's kind
of unfair like there'll be like some
dialogue and I'll be like man this
dialogue ain't [ __ ] with the original
Game of Thrones one but that's because
that the guy George R Martin was in his
[ __ ] basement for 30 years writing
these things right no friends loser so
the thing
no for real like you didn't have a lot
of friends right there's no way
there's no way you can make something
that great so funny because you're
praising him all the time and for no
reason you just go because he's such a
great writer spends so much time on this
[ __ ] loser yeah because I could do it
if I didn't have friends
[Music]
I have to believe there's something that
he had that I didn't have billionaires
are evil they must be that's why I'm not
a billionaire I could be a billionaire
too there's a fire by the way so yeah
that's why he can't finish up the other
[ __ ] because now that he got some Faith
he got some friends now now
okay so first season two Duds the rest
pretty goddamn good yeah
the fact that we have to wait two years
my suspicion is HBO didn't know if they
were going to renew it because if they
knew that they were going
they were going with it they
pre-production they'd already it's like
Source materials there it's not like it
takes that much longer to flip it it's
not like they gotta write a whole new
story The story's there I think they had
their slate already for the shows that
they're going to put out and their
budgets for each of these shows so now
they just gotta wait interesting which I
think is a bummer because it built a
crazy amount of [ __ ] momentum do you
think maybe there it kind of helped that
it's after Game of Thrones because Game
of Thrones ended so badly but we all
loved it so much that we're dying for
the next thing so we're like oh here's
another thing George R Martin actually
wrote this maybe it helped in that way
that's a great [ __ ] point I don't
know why you're talking right now but
you did you did bring an unbelievable
knowing what we're talking and it's it
is absolutely infuriating yeah
absolutely
that's crazy this is absolutely
inferiorating that you made such a
brilliant Point without knowing what the
[ __ ] we're talking about I have no idea
who it's almost like you should not read
anything anymore
let's talk about Valeria the dragon yeah
[Laughter]
come on now okay
um
I feel like the show last episode
finally sets up what we wanted
you okay so the first season I don't
think that's what a lot of us wanted I
think I wanted a lot of like we wanted
the war we wanted the games we wanted
the chess match we wanted the
outsmarting and the first one was like
it's really hard to squeeze a baby out
of your [ __ ] right and I feel like now
we got the babies out let's get to the
fun part nah they made that excuse me
did you see this last episode that [ __ ]
look hard bro
she had all the nurses in the room
what's the biggest [ __ ] you ever took
say again the biggest [ __ ] ever yeah
you've ever taken never hurt
but what is the biggest hypothetically
pounds I don't know four to seven yeah
I think that's a bad that's a bad pair
like a [ __ ] is soft I've [ __ ] them
baby
they're not as soft as [ __ ] it's soft
somebody says hard
some of my [ __ ] harder than baby what
does it sound like if you had an eight
pound card you had an eight pound hard
[ __ ] that'd be that's something that'd
be like childhood no I've had four to
seven pounds [ __ ] that was hard
I had to get up off the seat and lifted
you up like just squeezed it what am I
doing up here exactly bump your legs on
the seat like this my feet was dangling
bro yeah my feet were dangling I was
just up Six Flags again bro literally
literally so so it's okay my man it's
okay
all right bro everything's gonna be just
fine okay uh what were we talking about
you've been having a baby [ __ ] which I
don't think you've had oh yeah the show
the focus on how difficult it is to have
a baby bro it's like
it ain't that hard for come on bro
maybe for white women
you know what I'm saying I don't know if
that's a good thing
ain't no way Latinas are going through
that every single time
that they have a baby oh yeah after the
first one I'm just exactly
[Laughter]
so so I'm cool as hell look cool as hell
dragon
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so Alec Baldwin or something
you're just doing so good so how's the
dragon I feel like the story is finally
in a place that we're more accustomed to
which is it's wartime who's gonna win
how are you gonna outsmart your opponent
we get to see the dragons fight that
little that tiny little dragon fighting
scene fire
right right I should I was like oh oh
[ __ ] but Larry in a Munch
that was dope that was and I like the
fact that they lost control of the
Dragons yep so the idea before is that
you the dragon just does whatever the
[ __ ] you want but then they've also said
in the series you don't control a dragon
I forget
viserys uh warns that we don't control
the dragons like they're they're too
powerful right and that we should be
careful of like the hubris we have
around track yeah and respect the power
that they have and uh I thought that was
really cool and now this whole War has
started because yeah they think they
didn't respect the hubris yeah they
didn't he he chased after him and then
they sort of lost control of the Dragon
he was trying to stun him a little bit
Yeah and then the dragons were like oh
it's go time yeah and uh yeah I just
thought that was really interesting I
think the world is set up also shorty
loses her kid and I thought that was
really cool moment you watched like the
after thing but like she's lost
everybody right she's lost her father
she's lost her mother she's lost all
these different figures in her life but
when Rainier loses her son
that's when she understands loss and now
is go time yeah like it is turned around
and I faced I was like oh this [ __ ]
soft compared to what this [ __ ] about
to do and I think it's gonna get Gnarly
I know for a fact it's gonna get
annoying them
um any other thoughts miles uh I mean I
thought it was really well done
obviously I'm not saying that they
didn't do it well but I weirdly wish
that they went after it in a different
way what do you mean I wish they used uh
instead of doing these like huge time
jumps and like us having to be like 10
years later six years later whatever in
those first few episodes start with the
adult characters in episode one have
flashbacks have flashbacks yeah like let
us sort of like learn the history
through them explaining it to each other
and being like when he goes Emma emini
saying for his wife
give us a flashback to what he did to
Emma like it starting on that was sort
of impactful but I thought it would be
really interesting if they would have
done yeah Game of Thrones did that with
bram's flashbacks right Bram was like in
the tree or whatever and then he'd CEO's
story through flashbacks again again
okay oh God damn it's not watching stuff
dude yeah I'm done I'm done reading I'm
done watching yeah
I just started I just started I watched
Black Adam me and Alex actually it was
me Alex all the guys in the studio yeah
the movie that I invited him to and paid
for myself
you doing why didn't you go that's crazy
he didn't say he was gonna go but wait
but yeah I invited him you could have
been I did I did I did I did invited
everybody out there at the table yeah I
definitely do it for sure I definitely
did did you you got the invite right
yeah we all got the invite I got the
invite he was I never got him he was
right there at the table and he was like
he got the end he's like
um I never got an invite
and I was like oh that's how annoying
yeah do it again he was like oh
I don't think
nobody I reacted that's exactly what he
did I'm sure we could just go look at a
text thread to see look at the text this
is in person
you know you won't be listening yeah I
texted him I remember where you were
sitting at him where he was sitting
where was I said you were sitting over
on the right corner maybe I was doing
something to provide money for us that's
fine and then I was thinking about going
to watch movies like a child exactly I'm
doing his little childish things
with all of the guys because he gave me
a nose he didn't say no you should have
just called him and said hey man we're
all going to the movies
I think that we should invite all of our
friends because Mark you asked me if I
wanted to go to the movie no no I said
I'm already here you're not invited Mark
that's a lie Mark you were you were
trying to drop off a gift or something
to me was it that [ __ ] picture that
you framed what picture that friend you
was true you're trying to drop something
off to me remember are you at your house
yeah it's a secret I haven't given it to
you yet oh my God it's for your birthday
now actually but your birthday's coming
up yeah my birthday is coming up yeah
exactly dude it's gonna be fire it's
gonna be great just ruin his president
or something like that nah not enough
but yeah we got a lot of birthdays in
October bro we're gonna have to spread
these things when have you been going
hard on birthdays yeah if you give a
[ __ ] about birthdays now you're like
it's this person's birthday he's married
now
nice
[Laughter]
invite him to the movie no somebody said
somebody said it last night they're like
I think it's after you were at uh after
your wedding yeah we said he got a new
software update after his wedding oh
yeah
how many was he missing before the
wedding a couple of years
a couple Generations yeah yeah yeah no I
like the idea of like uh giving somebody
that feeling and celebrating them do you
remember last year before the wedding
when the birthdays were having he said
you guys didn't do it your mom did it
yeah I do remember that is also true
y'all didn't do nothing and they said
your mom didn't even suffer when she did
a childbirth is easy that's what you
said it's easier than they make a scene
when that show was sucked you're crazy
it's easy y'all y'all y'all are like the
[ __ ] fentanyl George Floyd people
about this wow you the conspiracy
theorists I say it's hard yeah
[ __ ] be ripping they'd be [ __ ]
they're built to rip they're built to
rip they're built just like a Ford built
that built Four Tops they are built to
rip I do think that I think listen you
can't believe in evolution and believe
is hard but you can also believe in
child death and maternal death yeah what
what do you mean
what do you mean you're doing a
documentary thing we don't really know
how Evolution works and you're just
saying things this is you haven't read
any Evolution here like but do you know
evolution
no disrespect okay to women we need them
we need thank you so much Angels sweet
sweet angels Ismail on my angle probably
not
sweet angels thank you so much for
creating life and bringing life into
this world without you we would be
nothing literally we will not exist
without you thank you so much for what
you're doing okay that being said
it's a little cup
dude it's a little cap right like this
is how you know his cat
when you [ __ ] something else up in your
body you don't go can I get an epidural
okay wow you go let me do that you have
something better
[Laughter]
because he's like you [ __ ] something
else up you're not like yo give me the
most painful injection and none of the
pain possible yeah this is part of the
documentary like that expert comes in
and starts [ __ ] up the whole thing
hey ladies yeah
ladies ladies ladies ladies
leave it I'm sorry about that epidural
comment that was
we could be wrong about things you know
what I mean the reality is I think
having a child come out of your [ __ ] is
probably very difficult
very difficult also it can't be easy to
come out or it would probably fall out
another important like a giraffe Real
Talk you've seen it happen with animals
all the time falls out super slippery
yeah 100 hurts the animal and we that
soft Noggin still soft yeah right Shifty
perfect example
right yeah yeah Shifty that he might
have he might have fell out they're
involved in a fender bender on the way
home from the hospital I think I
honestly think his head at the window
and it was like a cartoon that's it it
might it might be it so
I think that what I think having a child
is incredibly difficult there's no
question it's probably painful I do
think that you are built and equipped to
handle that yes is that fair to say but
that's affirming that's a feminist
comment that's like oh your body's
powerful yeah you have the ability to
handle power yeah exactly my body's not
powerful enough to do that well you said
it kind of was you could do a seven to
eight pound [ __ ] no but that's totally
different if you don't think your body's
equipped to handle that I'm on board now
totally different I have a lot of
respect for what women go through a
chopper it's not as hard as how it is
and how's the dragons Okay let's just
keep going you don't think yeah how are
you
no I have it but I'm just saying it
seems uh no it's that hard
yeah all right there you go that's your
ballot it's that hard have you seen one
yes when in nursing school you saw a
baby come out yeah I had to see too yeah
what was it like
nasty how many people are there uh
doctor nurse I seen it too when I was uh
yeah everybody else and me whoa yeah and
they look super painful yeah yeah it
looks horrendous yeah I was in the room
they were like I was doing this class
like clinical rotations they let me
watch yeah and then the babies
[ __ ] get his head out of there and
then there's just like blood and [ __ ]
flies everywhere and I felt bad because
they like gave me permission to go but
then when the [ __ ] started like coming
all over the room I did this
like you're out of shampoo yeah I was at
SeaWorld and I just looked like the
biggest [ __ ] ever but it was
disgusting dude the C-section was gross
too but I thought that was less gross
yeah I saw the C-section too how long
were you in middle school
School clinical rotations you do
rotations in a bunch of different parts
of the hospital they let high schoolers
just go look at a woman's vagina yeah
that's right yeah first vagina I saw
that's all you were virgin for so long
you're like you're like traumatized dude
I think one of my only issue with House
of dragon is that they make a childbirth
look easy okay
I think that's what I hope in the future
seasons is that when we do see trial
birth childbirth we'll we'll experience
the trials and tribulations that go
along with it the intense pain the risk
to the mother's life so often so often
so they had to do that because there's
so many babies that are being born
throughout this time that it's like all
right it would just be boring just to
just show them all right they're
pregnant they gave birth so it's like
you just add a little something yeah a
little there's like so many kids that
are being born I'll be honest my wife
might be on your on your side she
delivered a baby as her as her job and
she says she hates how it's depicted in
uh in Hollywood and in movies why she's
like she's like it's always shown as
like this like traumatic like painful
like yeah it's a beautiful thing I hate
my life thing some people like can be
laughing during some people can it can
be orgasmic and sexual she's like
there's a lot of different ways that it
can be and it doesn't have to be uh to
your point your body is equipped for I'm
just saying what do you mean orgasmic
instead of old bucket [ __ ]
exactly I've heard this because it's big
that [ __ ] is big and it's getting all up
oh no are they making a thousands
son how you're responding is they sound
like dumb yelling
some people I need to see a girl bust a
nut to baby coming out man that would be
great somebody imagine being a dad
watching your son make your wife come
bro you
gotta fight that [ __ ] like yeah
do they rather [ __ ] when it's coming out
like is the baby coming out and they're
just like
[Laughter]
hit the field
it's just like that actually uh yeah man
no someone would want nipple stipulation
while uh while they're giving birth oh
I'd do that is that a job no you have to
do it to them that's what I'm saying I
thought you meant to you no I'd squeeze
them tits yeah you don't think I squeeze
up why do they want acidic tits to come
yeah it helps I think it helps with
stimulation
if you're like closed off and like tied
intense it's going to make it harder to
get out of the vaginal Canal oh they
want to loosen it up kind of loose and
like healing Vibe it you know what I
mean someone with nipples yeah exactly
one time wow wait has your wife ever had
to squeeze knockers that's her only job
actually
she was so [ __ ] hot
can I send my wife to be like do like a
ride along yes if she's willing to be
the designated titty flicker then yeah
she can do it oh my Lord
I think it's beautiful out it's
beautiful why did you react not like
this are you stimulated right here
Alex just [ __ ] himself yeah